you had your kids
walk in your property line yeah as a
punishment gun line
okay okay so yeah because i guess your
mom was coming over and was
complaining about how bad the kids were
i'm sick of them
they they they don't know how to
they just they just get out of hand you
know they just get out of hand
we got to the point where they had three
four people coming in my house like
you know my engineer my security like
man we can't sleep every night but they
throwing water on us but i can't sleep
bro you know like i'm gone bro like
you know so your kids are just wild
just just turning up yeah just just out
of control bro
just get tired of it sometimes how many
kids you got hey
i mean [__] man that's a team bro i
should start in five and
that's a whole rotation in the finals
and only two of them live with me so
when all of them come like you know
they get rowdy bro get round and i'll be
able to put my foot down and
that's one way i put my foot down i
don't get tired of whooping bro
i don't want to whoop them all the time
you know so
i make them walk that fence for four or
five hours and take their phone
so
[Music]
yeah did you get any flack for like uh
for posting that
my mama your mom was not yeah that's why
i had him
pull him back in she called once you
know get my [__] grandchildren from
off that gate
with these my chance you should have put
me on the gate man
let me tell you something that's the
most annoying [__] cause i got two kids
and whenever they're grabbing like never
the grandparents
like bro you trying to stop let me
parent my nah they won't spoil them
it's like you do all this work with your
kids and then the grandparents will come
over for the weekend and [__] it all up
and let them do whatever they want let
them eat whatever they want give them
what they want
that's how it goes down bro i mean
that's really why they're grandparents i
guess
it's crazy because your your children
have had viral moments of their own like
right before
you got out of jail when your daughter
had that famous yeah
i told y'all [__] oh my god i was
living in tampa at the time i told y'all
[__]
and i just remember like that video
coming out
i think was the first show you did out
of jail was it in orlando
or was that like the second show it was
like the second third
i just remember man florida was on fire
for you boozy when you when you first
got out bro i
i never seen no energy like that any at
any time bro living in the south
when you were fresh out bro it was it
was it was it was crazy
um but yeah but like how's your daughter
doing the daughter that was in that
video did she like did she realize how
like famous she was for
that for that point in time because that
video was [__] everywhere
i'm kind of having trouble with her
right now so because she's older now
right how old is she
she like 14 13 14.
so
she's been fighting this [__] all on
instagram i miss my baby
i ain't saying that i will mama right
now but i miss my baby